Justin Halley Bieber have their big
wedding celebration yesterday South
Carolina after tying the knot in a New
York courthouse in September 2018 that
their big celebration last night yeah so
Justin posted the first pics of the
couple after the celebration on
Instagram - at 5:11 a.m. so we're
thinking he hadn't gone to bed just yet
they had a ceremony at the Somerset
Chapel and then headed to the montage
palmetto Bluff resort which is a twenty
thousand acre waterfront resort check
out Hailey's Slean leather jacket during
a night life oh now there's plenty of
celebrity guests check out this group
shot that includes Jaden Smith Kylie
Jenner who I guess is over her serious
flu now she's really down and out there
for a while right and Kendall Jenner now
check out the video that Kendall posted
on Instagram showing off her dress I
love this now I love it the guy that
she's walking with knows to get out of
the frame get out of this guy here's
another where she was real close on her
face it's a little bit creepy this is
inside the venue somewhere she really
wants to get close to the face be out
what's that guy what's yet ready ready
oh that one guess that surprised some
people was Caitlyn beetles Caitlyn and
Justin dated over ten years ago so when
they were real young there she is riding
a golf cart with her brother Christian
now some guests also showed off the
packages the guests got like custom
water bottles
that's a Halley and Justin of course
there was champagne a big bottle bottle
of Moet with a custom the Bieber's and
the wedding date on the bottle do you
find it weird like that people invite
exes I think that's difficult at night I
think that this is I think this is fun I
think there's a lot of people like
you're sort of first girlfriend first
boyfriend that you you know realized
what it was and you grow up and you just
have nothing but respect to love and and
I think that with Justin Bieber and his
whole sort of transformation and
everything else I think that what he may
be doing which makes sense is one to
invite her was to sort of surround
yourself or at least have people at that
wedding at that moment who knew you
before you bring this right you know
those are the people from the life you
had before everything sort of went
bananas and so it makes perfect sense to
me he probably still really really loves
a girl I don't know how close they are
but but I'm all for it the rats they
look great together but I mean did we do
wonder if from
the other X is invited oh no the other X
is not invited